From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. It's the first day of high school, Salt Lake City. A bunch of students are standing around outside in clusters, and the seniors are wearing little kid backpacks-- Ninja Turtles, Hello Kitty, Spider-man. Big 17-, 18-year-old kids in Winnie-the-Pooh backpacks. My colleague Miki Meek talked to seniors Estrella and Angie.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。今天是盐湖城高中的开学第一天。一群学生三三两两地站在外面，高年级学生背着小孩子的书包——忍者神龟、凯蒂猫、蜘蛛侠。17、18岁的大孩子背着小熊维尼的书包。我的同事Miki Meek采访了高三学生Estrella和Angie。
So, you guys, what is the deal with-- what's up with the backpacks? Why is this a senior thing?
那么，你们几个，这是怎么回事？书包是怎么回事？为什么这成了高三生的传统？
'Cause we enter school, kindergarten, with kids' backpacks, you know? 'Cause we're little kids. And then we're leaving school with these on as well.
因为我们刚进学校时，上幼儿园时，背的就是这种小书包，你知道吗？因为那时我们还是小孩子。现在我们快要毕业了，也要背上这些。
Do you guys have any specific plans you've already made for this year that you want to do together because it is your senior year?
你们今年有没有制定什么特别的计划，因为是最后一年，想要一起去完成？
Actually, on Thursday or tomorrow, we're going to go change our classes so we can be together more and make sure we have the same lunches and stuff.
其实，周四或者明天，我们要去改选课程，这样我们就能多待在一起，确保午饭时间什么的都在一起。
Yeah.
对。
You guys are in how many classes together?
你们有多少门课是一起的？
Zero.
零门。
[LAUGHS] Yeah, we have none.
[笑] 是的，一门都没有。
So what's your plan for trying to get the same classes?
那你们打算怎么争取上同样的课呢？
We're going to beg our counselor. We're going to be like, we have separation anxiety. We have to be together. I'm going to be like, Mark-- that's his name, Mark. I'll be like, Mark, please let us be together. We want to enjoy our senior year, you know? It's our last year together because we're both going different ways.
我们要去求我们的辅导员。我们要说，我们有分离焦虑症。我们必须在一起。我会说，马克——那是他的名字，马克。我会说，马克，请让我们在一起吧。我们想享受高三生活，你知道吗？这是我们在一起的最后一年了，因为我们要各奔东西了。
They are really feeling the last timeness of this year ahead of them, the last year in these classes, in these halls, in backpacks, the last year of these friendships in this place, with these people. After this, their lives will be different.
她们确实感受到了这种“最后一次”的氛围：未来这一年是最后一年，要在这些教室里，走过这些走廊，背着这些书包，在这所学校、和这些人一起度过这段友谊的最后时光。此后，她们的生活将会截然不同。
All the seniors we talked to had a list of things you have to do senior year, stuff they'd seen other kids do before them, and also all the iconic experiences they'd seen in a million movies and TV shows. This school, in fact, is actually the school from High School Musical. It was filmed here.
我们采访的所有高三生都有一个“必做清单”，都是她们看到学长学姐做过的，还有无数电影和电视剧里那些标志性的体验。事实上，这所学校正是《歌舞青春》的取景地，就是在这里拍摄的。
Anyway, they all have lists that include the classics-- prom, football games, homecoming, senior sunrise, senior sunset, senior parties, senior memory boxes-- that's a thing that was new to me, along with--
总之，她们都有包含经典项目的清单——舞会、橄榄球赛、返校节、高三晨曦日、高三夕阳日、高三派对、高三记忆盒——这对我来说是个新鲜事，还有……
There's this thing called trash bagging.
有个叫“垃圾袋滑行”的项目。
What is that?
那是什么？
It's like when it's raining, you put on a trash bag and slide down hills.
就是下雨的时候，套上垃圾袋从山上滑下来。
So do you step into the trash bag?
你们是钻进垃圾袋里吗？
Yeah, make holes for your legs and arms probably, like over you on a swimsuit, kind of. I've never done it.
对，大概要在上面挖出腿和胳膊的洞，就像穿在泳衣外面一样。我还没试过。
So she has to. Looming over each rite of passage, no matter how stupid, is the fear that if you don't go for it, you could miss something really special, something fleeting. You have one chance at senior year. You have to grab it. You have to go big.
所以她必须得试一次。每个通过仪式的背后，无论看起来多么愚蠢，都笼罩着一种恐惧：如果你不尝试，可能会错过一些非常特别、转瞬即逝的东西。高三只有一次机会。你必须抓住它。你必须玩得尽兴。
Ferris Bueller's Day Off is my number one inspiration.
《春天不是读书天》是我最大的灵感来源。
This is Vasey.
这是Vasey。
I want to be him. I don't know if I'm well-known enough to become East High's Ferris Bueller, but that's my goal, is to take an extraordinary crazy day off that will be talked about for generations.
我想成为他那样的人。我不知道自己是否出名到足以成为东高中的费里斯·布勒，但我的目标就是度过一个非凡而疯狂的假期，让人们传颂几代人。
She's still working on a plan for that. But in the meantime, Vasey's got many other plans. Vasey says she spent most of high school going back home to her hole to study. Not this year. So when she got an invite to a pink party for senior girls, something Vasey never would have gone to before, she went for it.
她还在策划具体的方案。但与此同时，Vasey还有很多别的计划。Vasey说她高中大部分时间都躲在家里学习。今年不再这样了。所以当她收到一个高三女生粉色派对的邀请时，尽管这是Vasey以前绝不会去的地方，她还是去了。
I wore a pink babydoll dress. I have knee-high go-go boots that I wore. And I stole my mom's pearls to wear because it was kind of a formal event. And it's a tradition that the girls all jump in the pool. So me and my friends jumped in the pool.
我穿了一件粉色的娃娃裙。我还穿了一双过膝的舞靴，偷戴了我妈妈的珍珠项链，因为这算是个正式场合。女孩子们跳进泳池是个传统，所以我和朋友们都跳了进去。
I was talking with my friends the other day, and we said that it's kind of fun to-- we complain about it a lot, but it's kind of fun to just be a girl going to an American public high school because you get that kind of Americana high school thing, you know? Being a senior is this hyped-up event. So it's kind of like I get to do all of the cheesy things that they do in the coming of age movies that make me feel like I really am just an American teenage girl. [LAUGHS]
那天我和朋友聊天时说，抱怨归抱怨，作为一名在美国公立高中就读的女孩其实挺有趣的，因为你能体验那种典型的美式高中生活，你知道吗？作为一名高三生是一件备受瞩目的事。所以我可以去尝试所有青春电影里那些俗套的桥段，这让我感觉自己真的是一名美国高中女生。[笑]
I feel like I've got to be happy with what I've done and feel satisfied with what I've done.
我觉得我必须对我所做的一切感到快乐，对我所做的一切感到满足。
Like doing everything?
比如把所有事都做一遍？
Doing everything until it's worn out, and so I feel like I have no unfinished business at East High.
把所有事做到尽兴，这样我就觉得在东高中没有遗憾了。
Senior year-- just the idea of it, with all its rituals and big feelings and corsages, it's so powerful, people across the world know about the American high school experience. It's an American export.
高三——光是这个概念，伴随着所有的仪式、强烈的情感和胸花，就非常有影响力。全世界的人都知道美国高中的体验。这是一种美国的出口文化。
I've been following one kid who came to America as an exchange student and committed herself to the senior year experience in a way I have never seen before. She and a group of kids from all over the world showed up with Ferris Bueller and High School Musical in their heads, with their own ambitions of having the best year ever and going home with great memories, no experience or opportunity missed. Today's show, "It's Senior Year." Stay with us.
我一直在跟踪记录一个来美国的交换生，她投入到高三体验中的方式是我从未见过的。她和一群来自世界各地的孩子带着《春天不是读书天》和《歌舞青春》的愿景来到这里，心中怀揣着度过史上最棒一年的抱负，想要带着美好的记忆回家，不留任何遗憾，不错过任何机会。今天的节目主题是“高三生活”。请继续关注。
It's This American Life. Act One, "YES 2024." One of the many programs that brings international high school students to the United States is the YES Program-- the Youth Exchange and Study Program. The program is run by the State Department. It was created after 9/11 for students from places with a significant Muslim population. The kids come to the US, spend a year at an American high school, live with an American family, and, quote, "engage in activities to learn about the US society and values."
这是《美国生活》。第一幕，“YES 2024”。YES计划（青年交流与学习计划）是众多将国际高中生带到美国的项目之一。该项目由国务院运营。它是在9/11事件后为来自穆斯林人口众多的地区的学生设立的。孩子们来到美国，在美国高中度过一年，寄宿在美国人家中，并“参与各种活动以了解美国社会和价值观”。
YES is a really hard program to get into. Kids spend years preparing to apply. They need excellent grades, excellent English skills, written and verbal. There's an interview, a vetting process. About 30,000 students apply every year, and around 3% get in. In 2023, 500 kids from Gaza applied to the YES program. 13 got in, and one of those was Majd.
YES项目的录取难度非常大。孩子们要花几年时间准备申请。他们需要优秀的成绩，出色的英语能力（笔试和口语）。还有面试和审查过程。每年约有3万人申请，录取率约为3%。2023年，有500名来自加沙的孩子申请了YES项目。13人被录取，Majd就是其中之一。
OK, so when I first heard about it, it's like, oh, my god. Like, that seems like the perfect life for me, and I want to go there.
好的，当我第一次听说这个项目时，天哪，我觉得这对我来说就是完美的生活，我一定要去。
The YES program was Majd's idea, not her parents'. Majd is a kid who has plans for herself. You can feel the propulsion forward when you sit with Majd. It's exhilarating, sometimes terrifying, like riding shotgun with a highly competent, yet speeding, driver.
YES项目是Majd自己的主意，不是她父母的。Majd是个有规划的孩子。当你和Majd坐在一起时，你能感受到她那种向前的推动力。这让人兴奋，有时甚至有点吓人，就像坐在一辆由非常能干但开得飞快的司机驾驶的副驾驶座上。
Majd heard about YES from kids who had already done it, YES alumni in Gaza, young adults who told Majd about their year going to high school in America.
Majd是从那些已经参加过该项目的孩子那里听说YES的，那是加沙的YES校友，他们告诉Majd关于他们在美国高中生活的一年。
And they told me about the application process and everything. So I started preparing really early.
他们告诉了我申请过程等等。所以我很早就开始准备了。
What did they say about it?
他们是怎么描述这个项目的？
Some of them described it to me as if it was like absolute heaven. You're partying every day. You're getting five Domino pizza boxes every day. [LAUGHS] Yeah, no, for me, honestly, all my life, I haven't been the fun, going out kid. I was really focused on academics. And I like the idea of the 4.0 scale GPA. Like--
有人把它描述得像是绝对的天堂。每天都在派对，每天都有五盒达美乐披萨。[笑] 不，其实对我来说，我从小到大都不是那种喜欢出去玩的孩子。我非常专注于学术。我喜欢4.0分制的绩点概念……
I love that other people were excited about Domino's pizza, and you were excited about the 4.0 grade scale.
我喜欢别人因为达美乐披萨而兴奋，而你却因为4.0的绩点而兴奋。
Yes. I mean, yeah. I mean, I kind of have a reasonable explanation for that. But--
是的。我是说，是的。我有一个合理的解释。但是……
Her explanation goes like this. Majd wanted a perfect transcript. She wants to be eligible for the best scholarships to study astrophysics at the best university, maybe in Gaza or maybe in the US. Princeton looks interesting to her. Majd doesn't want a stray 99% grade to get in the way of where she's going.
她的解释是这样的。Majd想要一张完美的成绩单。她希望自己有资格获得最好的奖学金，去最好的大学学习天体物理学，可能是在加沙，也可能是在美国。普林斯顿大学对她很有吸引力。Majd不想因为哪怕0.01分的差距而阻碍她的前程。
Literally, point to point really makes a difference. Like, if you get 99.6%, you get a scholarship. But if you get 99.5%, which is a 4.0, you don't get the scholarship.
真的是差之毫厘谬以千里。比如，如果你拿到99.6%，就能获得奖学金。但如果你拿到99.5%，也就是4.0，你就拿不到奖学金了。
How old were you when you figured all of this out?
你是什么时候发现这些的？
Pretty young, I'd say, sixth grade?
很小的时候，大概六年级？
She applied along with her friend, Abdulrahman. He goes by Aboud. And on February 16, 2023, they both got in. Majd was 15 years old.
她和朋友Abdulrahman一起申请，他大家都叫他Aboud。2023年2月16日，他们都收到了录取通知。Majd当时15岁。
And we both started screaming on the phone. And all the neighbors heard me. And, oh, my god, it was truly sensational.
我们在电话里都尖叫起来。邻居们都听见了。哦，天哪，那真是太震撼了。
In Gaza, YES alumni are sort of like influencers. They're a little famous, at least to the kids trying to get into the program. They post on Instagram from their year in America. And when they get back, they'd hold assemblies and run programs and seemed like the best of friends. The YES groups had a real bond.
在加沙，YES校友就像是网红。他们有点名气，至少在那些想参加该项目的孩子眼里是这样。他们在Instagram上发布在美国一年的生活。回国后，他们会召开大会、组织项目，看起来像是最好的朋友。YES小组之间有着真正的纽带。
Majd and her group of 13 would be their own crew. They'd be YES '24 for 2024. Some of them knew each other, and some met for the first time on a bus trip to Jerusalem to get their visas, a day they all talk about as incredible. One of them told me best day of his life, a day they really got close as a group.
Majd和她的13人小组将成为他们自己的团队。他们是“YES 24”，代表2024届。有些人互相认识，有些人是在去耶路撒冷签证的巴士上第一次见面，那一天大家都说是不可思议的一天。其中一人告诉我那是他一生中最美好的一天，那是他们作为一个团体真正亲近起来的一天。
There was Majd and Aboud. There was Fatima, an exuberant 15-year-old, an extrovert from a family of introverts who could picture the whole year ahead of her.
有Majd和Aboud。还有Fatima，一个充满活力的15岁女孩，她是内向家庭里的外向者，她能想象出前方整整一年的画面。
You know like in the movies, like locker room. You go on a school bus. You have a lot of friends that play sports. You play sports by yourself. And then they would always mention, in every single American high school movie, basketball or football.
你知道电影里的那种更衣室吗。坐校车。有很多玩运动的朋友。你自己也玩运动。然后他们总是会提到，在每一部美式高中电影里，篮球或橄榄球。
What movies are you thinking of?
你在想哪些电影？
Like, oh, I remember "Mean Girls."
比如，《贱女孩》。
Oh, yeah. Mm-hmm. And that made you want to go to an American high school?
噢，是的。那让你想去美国读高中？
Yeah, actually. Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是的，确实。[笑]
I got placed in Oklahoma, in a small town.
我被分配到了俄克拉荷马州的一个小镇。
I barely ever heard of Minnesota before. Of course I know of Prince. I knew Bob Dylan.
在此之前，我几乎没听过明尼苏达。当然我知道王子（Prince），我知道鲍勃·迪伦。
I was like, oh, I love Maine. But I was scared because nobody's there. I don't know anybody there. And it's in the end of the map.
我当时心想，噢，我喜欢缅因州。但我很害怕，因为那里没人。我不认识那里任何人。而且它在地图的尽头。
Oh, my gosh. I waited for so long, and I got somewhere that's worth it. California is probably like a cool place, you know? I pictured Los Angeles, but then, ooh, Northern California, Redding. I mean, so country.
噢，天哪。我等了那么久，结果去了一个值得去的地方。加州可能是一个很酷的地方，你知道吗？我想象的是洛杉矶，结果是北加州的雷丁。我的意思是，太乡村了。
I mean, yes, I wanted New York City or California, but I mean, I was like, oh, OK, Ohio. Well, let's discover Ohio.
我是说，是的，我想要去纽约市或加州，但我当时想，噢，好吧，俄亥俄州。好吧，让我们探索一下俄亥俄吧。
In August 2023, Majd leaves Gaza. She says goodbye to her mom, dad, and younger sister. The YES '24 kids arrive in Washington, DC and take a group photo.
2023年8月，Majd离开加沙。她向妈妈、爸爸和妹妹告别。YES 24的孩子们抵达华盛顿特区，拍了一张集体照。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[外语演讲]
And then they all scatter. It's the last time they'll be together before the end of the program. September 2023, Majd heads to Washington State, a city called Bremerton, a Navy town about an hour and a half drive from Seattle.
然后他们都散开了。这是他们在项目结束前最后一次聚在一起。2023年9月，Majd前往华盛顿州的布雷默顿，那是一个海军小镇，距离西雅图大约一个半小时车程。
In her first few weeks in Bremerton, Majd studied her new school like she studied for exams. She took mental notes. The ROTC kids are higher status. Being in a relationship-- highly valued. Academics-- less so. The thing Majd noticed American teenagers seemed to value above all else, though, was fun. Majd did not think of herself as fun.
在布雷默顿的最初几周，Majd像复习考试一样研究她的新学校。她暗自记下心得：ROTC（预备役军官训练团）学生地位更高。谈恋爱——非常受重视。学术——反而没那么重要。Majd注意到美国青少年似乎最看重的一件事是——快乐。Majd并不认为自己是个“快乐”的人。
She didn't exactly think of herself as a teenager either. Majd is always more comfortable talking with adults. But no matter. She was here to succeed as an American high schooler. So she became a student of fun. She told me incredulously, when they finished a unit in class, the teacher had a raffle with prizes. She took a video and showed it to me. Just look, she said, pointing at all the kids cheering.
她也不认为自己是个“青少年”。Majd总是更愿意和成年人交谈。但没关系。她是来这里作为一名美式高中生取得成功的。于是，她开始学习如何“快乐”。她惊讶地告诉我，当班里学完一个单元后，老师举办了一场抽奖活动。她录了一段视频给我看。快看，她指着欢呼的孩子们说。
[CHEERING, LAUGHTER]
[欢呼声，笑声]
Typical American high school.
典型的高中生活。
What makes that typical American high school?
什么让你觉得这是典型的高中生活？
I don't know. I've noticed that they're very loud. I'm just not-- one time, I remember I tried to cheer like they do. It didn't work out. It just-- yeah, I can't scream.
不知道。我注意到他们非常吵。我只是……有一次我记得我试着像他们那样欢呼。没成功。只是……是的，我无法尖叫。
When did you try it?
你什么时候试的？
Like for a basketball game. And all the vibes were great, and we were having fun. But I said, OK, let me try. But then, yeah, I just felt so kind of out of place. Like, what am I doing? Why am I screaming? [LAUGHS] So, yeah.
在一场篮球比赛中。氛围很好，我们玩得很开心。但我说，好吧，让我试试。但之后，我感觉自己太格格不入了。就像，我在干什么？我为什么要尖叫？[笑] 所以，是的。
What does it sound like when you try to cheer like an American?
当你试着像美国人那样欢呼时，听起来是什么样的？
For me, it sounds like a rat trying-- like I mean [LAUGHS] a rat dying.
对我来说，听起来像一只老鼠在……我的意思是[笑]一只老鼠快死了。
Majd was aware of all the ways she didn't fit in. Still, she wasn't miserable. She says she was the only Muslim in school, but she was kind of expecting that. Her host family, an older couple, was not a great match, but she moved in with a new host family-- better fit. She ate lunch in the nurse's office every day, but she liked the nurse. They talked.
Majd意识到她有很多地方不合群。尽管如此，她并没有感到痛苦。她说她是学校里唯一的穆斯林，但她早就预料到了。她的寄宿家庭是一对老夫妻，不太合适，但她搬到了一个新的寄宿家庭——更好一些。她每天在护士办公室吃午饭，但她喜欢那位护士。他们经常聊天。
And nothing deterred her. Her goal was being the very best YES student. YES kids are all encouraged to post on social media. Majd was excited by the possibility of her posts being reposted by the official YES account. So Majd went to everything-- football games--
没有任何事能阻挡她。她的目标是成为最好的YES学生。YES学生都被鼓励在社交媒体上发布动态。Majd对自己的动态被官方YES账号转发的可能性感到兴奋。所以Majd参加了一切活动——橄榄球赛——
[BAND PLAYING]
[乐队演奏]
--pep rallies--
——助威大会——
(SINGING) O say does that star spang--
(唱歌) 哦，那星条旗是否仍在飘扬……
--Homecoming.
——返校节。
(SINGING) Left foot, let's stomp
(唱歌) 左脚，让我们跺地。
Charlie Brown
查理·布朗。
It all went into her YES '24 highlight on Instagram. October, Majd must have been an American high schooler for less than six weeks when Hamas attacked Southern Israel, killed over 1,000 Israelis and took 251 people hostage.
这一切都进入了她Instagram上的“YES 24”精选里。10月，Majd成为美式高中生不到六周，哈马斯袭击了以色列南部，造成1000多名以色列人死亡，并劫持了251名人质。
Yeah, it was the weekend coming up, and it was about 9:00 or 10:00 PM. And I was just scrolling on Instagram on my phone. And then I saw some weird news videos. And I'm like, oh, my god, is that really happening?
是的，那个周末临近，大约是晚上9点或10点。我正躺在床上刷Instagram。然后我看到了一些奇怪的新闻视频。我心想，天哪，这是真的吗？
The next day, Majd couldn't reach her parents or younger sister. By Monday morning, she got news they were alive and at home, nothing more. By the end of that first week, it sounded dire.
第二天，Majd无法联系到她的父母和妹妹。周一早上，她得知他们还活着并在家里，仅此而已。第一周结束时，情况听起来很糟糕。
Hey, things are really bad. We don't have electricity. We don't have anything. And at that time, they were running low on food, too. And they were like-- everything was closed. And, yeah, I was very worried about them. And, yeah, I just started having a lot of nightmares.
嘿，情况真的很糟。我们没有电。我们什么都没有。那时他们的食物也快耗尽了。一切都关门了。我非常担心他们。我开始做噩梦。
Yeah, and they were trying not to tell me a lot of things for me not to worry here, but I already know a lot of things. They can't just hide it from me. And it was just very sad for me to see that they care about my safety and happiness and not about them. I was like, oh, my god, no. [SIGHS]
是的，他们试图不告诉我很多事情，以免我在这里担心，但我已经知道了很多。他们瞒不住我。看到他们关心我的安全和快乐，而不是他们自己，我感到非常难过。我说，噢，天哪，别这样。[叹气]
Did they explicitly tell you, don't worry about us?
他们明确告诉过你别担心他们吗？
Yes, they always-- and their messages, they said, "Oh, hi. Good morning. How are you? How's school? Have a great day. And don't worry about us. We're fine."
是的，他们总是这样。在他们的留言里，他们说：“噢，嗨。早上好。你好吗？学校怎么样？祝你度过美好的一天。别担心我们。我们很好。”
In those first few weeks, the 13 students from Gaza were all taking in a constant stream of news. Every day they were seeing explosions and rubble and bodies, one horrifying image after another.
在那最初的几周里，13名来自加沙的学生都在持续接收新闻流。他们每天都能看到爆炸、废墟和尸体，一个接一个可怕的画面。
But when they called their parents, who were in the place where those images were from, they got the same alarming positivity Majd was hearing-- "Hi, honey. How are you? We're fine. How was school? Have a great day." Fatima in Maine calling her parents.
但当他们给身处那里的父母打电话时，他们听到的却是和Majd听到的一样令人担忧的乐观——“嗨，亲爱的。你好吗？我们很好。学校怎么样？祝你度过美好的一天。”在缅因州的Fatima给父母打电话。
They don't ever tell me if they're doing OK or not. They're just like, "Oh, we're OK. Don't worry."
他们从不告诉我他们是否还好。他们只是说：“噢，我们很好。别担心。”
Shahd in Ohio.
俄亥俄州的Shahd。
They were trying to make me feel like all is good, but I know that my parents wouldn't tell me if something bad is actually happening with them. And that point was making me even more scared. It was making me way much more worried because I know that even if actually something terrible is happening, I wouldn't even know.
他们试图让我觉得一切都好，但我知道如果真的发生了什么坏事，我的父母是不会告诉我的。这一点让我更加害怕。这让我更加担心，因为我知道即使真的发生了可怕的事情，我也不会知道。
The kids couldn't go back to Gaza. Their parents wanted to protect them, protect their year. So the YES students watched as some of their homes were destroyed and then their neighborhoods disappeared. They were part of the war, but they were not part of the war.
这些孩子无法回到加沙。他们的父母想保护他们，保护他们的这一年。所以YES学生们眼睁睁看着他们的家被摧毁，他们的社区消失。他们身处战争之中，但又置身事外。
They were in Ohio, and Redding, California, and Snyder, Oklahoma. They were at soccer practice when their family packed up and fled their home. They were in class when they learned their school in Gaza had been flattened. They were eating at Red Lobster when they worried they'd lost touch with their parents.
他们在俄亥俄州、加州雷丁、俄克拉荷马州斯奈德。当他们的家人打包逃离家园时，他们正在参加足球训练。当他们得知加沙的学校被夷为平地时，他们正在上课。当他们担心与父母失去联系时，他们正在Red Lobster吃东西。
Shahd was in the bathroom at school when she saw a message on a group chat. Her friend back in Gaza was dead, killed with his mom and his sister. She went back to her photography class. They were in the midst of a group project.
Shahd在学校洗手间里看到了群聊里的消息。她在加沙的朋友死了，和他的妈妈、妹妹一起被炸死。她回到摄影课。他们正在进行小组作业。
We were kind of making a magazine cover, and we had to take pictures of our classmates. I took a picture of a guy named Caden. He was very friendly. I used him to make a rock star magazine.
我们当时正在制作一本杂志封面，我们需要拍同学的照片。我给一个叫Caden的男生拍了照。他很友好。我让他充当摇滚明星杂志的模特。
He'd be the rock star on the cover.
他就是封面上的摇滚明星。
He had some curly and frizzy hair, so I thought he would be cool for the scene. And I had him wear a leather jacket, and we got an electric guitar from the band. And I took a picture of him, and then I just continued working on the magazine.
他留着卷曲的头发，我觉得他很适合那个场景。我让他穿上皮夹克，我们从乐队那里借了一把电吉他。我拍了照片，然后就继续做杂志了。
Did you tell him your friend had died?
你没告诉他你的朋友死了吗？
No, I just didn't want anything to seem like, she's playing victim, or-- you know. I just don't like the hype of pretending to always be sad and always have a negative mood.
没，我只是不想让人觉得我在卖惨，或者……你知道的。我不喜欢那种假装总是很悲伤、总是处于消极情绪中的做派。
But you wouldn't have been pretending.
但你并不是在假装。
I mean, yeah, I guess it's just me. Because maybe none of them were close to me and none of them were really interested in knowing anything. So I was like, oh, it's fine. I can just go back to class. And that way, I can just forget. And maybe that would help me if I just practice my life normally.
我是说，是的，我想这就是我。因为也许他们中没有人跟我很亲近，也没有人真正对了解任何事感兴趣。所以我心想，噢，没关系。我可以回去上课。那样我就可以忘记了。也许如果我正常地过生活，会有所帮助。
This became the new imperative for all of them-- practice life normally. When Ali's friend was killed, he was in the middle of preparing a biology presentation. He went to biology class and did his presentation. It was on elephants.
这成了他们所有人的新准则——正常地过生活。当Ali的朋友去世时，他正在准备一份生物学演讲。他去上生物课并完成了演讲。主题是关于大象的。
Aboud saw a video of his best friend pulled from a pile of rubble. There was a news clip. He watched his friend on a stretcher. Aboud went to school, learned his friend's whole family had been killed-- dad, mother, grandparents, sisters. His friend and his youngest brother were the sole survivors. After school that day, Aboud went to a birthday party for his host sister. She was eight years old. He ate cake.
Aboud看到了一段视频，是他最好的朋友从废墟中被拉出来的画面。那是一条新闻片段。他看着朋友躺在担架上。Aboud去上学，得知朋友全家遇难——爸爸、妈妈、祖父母、姐妹。他的朋友和他最小的弟弟是唯一的幸存者。那天放学后，Aboud去参加了寄宿家庭妹妹的生日派对。她才8岁。他吃了蛋糕。
Practice life normally. Keep going. Present on elephants. Go to class. Ride the bus. Eat cake. Try to reach your parents on the phone. Try again. The cell service in Gaza kept going out. Majd kept trying.
正常过生活。继续前行。演讲关于大象的主题。去上课。坐校车。吃蛋糕。尝试通过电话联系父母。再试一次。加沙的移动网络不断中断。Majd不停地尝试。
I was just very worried about my family, especially, I remember, when Halloween came. I didn't talk to them for two weeks straight. And then it was Halloween, and I'm like, oh, my god, I'm dying to talk to them. And--
我只是非常担心我的家人，特别是，我记得万圣节来的时候。我有整整两周没和他们说话。然后万圣节到了，我心想，噢，天哪，我渴望和他们说话。然后……
You hadn't heard from them for two weeks?
你两周没从他们那里收到任何消息？
Yeah, no. But I still had to kind of put a mask on and be happy in front of people. For me, as an exchange student here, I still have to be participating in American cultural activities and stuff like that. So one of the activities was dressing up for Halloween and going trick or treating. But at the same time, people were dying in Gaza. And I'm like, OK, I want to make this quick, but just to still participate and make the family feel that, hey, I would love to participate in something that you do.
是啊，没收到。但我还是不得不戴上面具，在人们面前表现得快乐。对我来说，作为一名交换生，我仍然需要参与美国的文化活动之类的事情。所以其中一个活动就是万圣节装扮和去要糖果。但与此同时，加沙有人在死去。我心想，好吧，我想快点结束这一切，但还是要参与其中，让家人觉得，嘿，我很乐意参与你们做的事情。
What did you wear?
你穿了什么装扮？
Oh, I was Hermione Granger.
噢，我装扮成了赫敏·格兰杰。
You were Hermione?
你是赫敏？
[LAUGHS] I'm a huge Harry Potter fan.
[笑] 我是哈利·波特的超级粉丝。
She was practicing life normally. Majd shared a video of herself trick-or-treating in costume, running into another Potter fan.
她在正常地生活。Majd分享了一段自己化装要糖果的视频，撞见了另一个波特粉。
Oh!
噢！
What?
什么？
Come on!
来吧！
Oh, my god!
噢，天哪！
I love it!
我喜欢！
Another Harry Potter!
另一个哈利·波特！
Yes!
是的！
Yeah.
是啊。
Gryffindor!
格兰芬多！
From the moment Majd shared her Halloween post late that night, she could tell things had suddenly changed. The messages on Instagram came in a rush. A good friend of hers in Gaza--
从那天深夜Majd分享了万圣节动态开始，她能感觉到情况突然变了。Instagram上的消息蜂拥而至。她在加沙的一个好朋友——
How dare you? People are dying, and you're just living your life. Like, fighting me. Like, how dare you post something like that when your people are dying?
你怎么敢？人们在死去，而你却在生活。像是在跟我吵架。你的人民在死去的时候，你凭什么发布那种东西？
And another.
还有另一条。
Oh, my god, I can't believe that I chose you as one of my friends. Don't post any stories as if nothing is happening. Why would we blame the people in the West or abroad if our people are doing stuff like this?
噢，天哪，我不敢相信我竟然选了你当我的朋友。别发布那种好像什么都没发生过的故事。如果自己人做这种事，我们为什么要责怪西方人或海外人士？
There were more, many more. Where's your loyalty? You've betrayed us. You don't belong to Gaza. Why aren't you posting more about Palestine? Majd read every single one.
还有很多，更多。你的忠诚在哪里？你背叛了我们。你不属于加沙。为什么你不多发一些关于巴勒斯坦的内容？Majd阅读了每一条消息。
Here they were, 13 Palestinian teenagers trying to have their big, exciting year in America in the midst of the most immense tragedy imaginable. What would they do? What should they do? The weight of the war was landing on Majd, a teenager-- the exact moment in time when you were asked to make choices about who you are and who you are not, and when you are the most judged. And the judgment that was hardest for her to take were the comments from people in Gaza.
他们在这里，13名巴勒斯坦青少年试图在最难以想象的巨大悲剧中度过他们那宏大、激动人心的一年。他们会怎么做？他们应该怎么做？战争的重担落在了Majd这个青少年身上——在你被要求选择你是谁、不是谁，且最受评判的那个时间点。而最让她难以接受的评判，是来自加沙的人的评论。
Yeah, they just said that you're not one of us anymore, stuff like that. And I'm like, why are you guys attacking me? I'm doing an exchange here. I'm talking about Gaza every chance I can.
是的，他们只是说你不再是我们的一员了，诸如此类。我心想，你们为什么要攻击我？我在这里做交换生。我有机会就会谈论加沙。
And people here, they are living in their own bubble, at least high school teenagers. They don't really look at the news. They don't know a lot about what's going on. So most of their cares would be like, oh, did you watch the newest movie that came out? And I'm like, I can't really engage with you right now. It was very hard. You might notice me smiling a lot, but that's my trauma mechanism working.
而且这里的人，他们生活在自己的泡沫里，至少高中生是这样。他们并不真的看新闻。他们不太了解发生了什么。所以他们大部分的关心是，噢，你看过刚上映的新电影了吗？我心想，我现在真的无法和你交流。这非常难。你可能注意到我经常笑，那是我的创伤机制在起作用。
I had noticed how Majd would smile when talking about her tremendous loss, her fear for her parents and sister, smiling, when she told me her friend was killed, smiling. It was a little eerie how much you could see the effort to be OK on her face. She'd say, everyone hates me-- smile. More than 200 friends blocked me-- smile.
我注意到了Majd在谈论她的巨大损失、对父母和妹妹的恐惧时会露出微笑，当我告诉她她朋友去世时，她也露出微笑。当你能看到她脸上努力表现得“没关系”时，那种努力显得有点诡异。她说，大家都恨我——微笑。超过200个朋友屏蔽了我——微笑。
I lost a lot of friends. It was crazy. I mean, I lost some friends physically. They're not on Earth anymore. I lost some really close people that, oh, my god, they were a huge part of my life. And it was very hard.
我失去了很多朋友。这太疯狂了。我是说，我在身体上失去了朋友。他们不再在这个地球上了。我失去了一些非常亲近的人，天哪，他们是我生命中重要的一部分。这非常难。
I completely understood why people were upset that Majd was posting. And having spent time with Majd, I completely understood why she was posting. Majd came here to achieve something. She saw posting about her experiences as part of that.
我完全理解为什么人们对Majd发布动态感到不满。而和Majd相处后，我也完全理解她为什么要发布动态。Majd来到这里是为了实现某些目标。她将发布关于她经历的内容视为实现目标的一部分。
The program encourages kids to share stuff on social media. She liked sharing things for all the normal reasons. It's fun to show off what you're doing. But also for Majd, she saw it as an expectation that she wanted to meet. So she was especially confused when some of the YES students also seemed upset with her, stopped responding to her messages.
该项目鼓励孩子们在社交媒体上分享内容。她出于所有正常的理由喜欢分享。展示你在做什么很有趣。但对Majd来说，她也将这视为她想要达成的预期。所以当一些YES学生似乎也对她不满，停止回复她的消息时，她感到非常困惑。
It was very hard. I don't have support from Americans. I don't have support from Arabs, too, the students. I'm like, oh, my god, where do I go? What do I do?
这非常难。我没有美国人的支持。我也得不到阿拉伯学生的支持。我心想，噢，天哪，我该去哪里？我该怎么办？
November 2023. Majd didn't post anything for almost a month, and she focused all her attention on one thing-- her family. She went to school, she did her work, but mostly, she pleaded with her parents, when she could reach them, to please get out of Gaza, try to evacuate. But her dad didn't want to abandon their home, and they didn't have the money.
2023年11月。Majd几乎一个月没发布任何动态，她将全部注意力集中在一件事上——她的家人。她去上学，完成作业，但大多数时候，当她能联系到父母时，她哀求他们离开加沙，设法撤离。但她爸爸不想放弃家园，他们也没有钱。
Then she lost touch with them for almost three weeks. She waited to hear from them. And she wondered when she'd hear from the other YES students. She figured this was just a little blip. They'd get back in touch. But mostly, it was silence.
后来她和他们失去了联系，长达近三周。她等着他们的消息。她想知道什么时候能收到其他YES学生的消息。她以为这只是一个小插曲。他们会重新联系的。但大多数时候，只有沉默。
She'd see one of them posting something from their daily life on Instagram and think, so they are posting. Did that mean they weren't actually mad at her for posting? But if they weren't mad at her for posting, what happened, then? Why weren't they in touch with her? She never reached out to ask. She just wondered.
她看到其中一些人在Instagram上发布日常生活的内容，心想，原来他们还在发动态。这是否意味着他们并不是真的因为她发动态而生气？但如果他们不是因为她发动态而生气，那发生了什么？为什么他们不跟她联系？她从未去问过。她只是感到疑惑。
December 2023. Majd was living with a nurse named Tana Rode. Tana would watch Majd come and go from her room, always clutching her phone, sometimes her eyes puffy and red. Tana tried to keep the fridge stocked with parmesan cheese bagels from Costco. Majd seemed to like them, and it got her out of her room in the morning. Tana has a teenage daughter of her own. She was careful with Majd, stayed close, available, but gave Majd her space.
2023年12月。Majd住在一个名叫Tana Rode的护士家中。Tana会看着Majd进出房间，总是紧紧攥着手机，有时眼圈红肿。Tana试图让冰箱里装满Costco买的帕玛森芝士百吉饼。Majd似乎很喜欢，这让她早上能走出房间。Tana自己也有一个十几岁的女儿。她对Majd很小心，保持亲近、随时待命，但也给了Majd私人空间。
She's not one who will come down here and cry. I can just sense this heaviness in her, understandably. 'Cause she's happy. She's chatty. That girl loves to talk. So I can feel it when she's down.
她不是那种会下楼哭闹的孩子。我能感觉到她身上的那种沉重，这很正常。因为她本是个快乐、健谈的人。那女孩喜欢聊天。所以我能感觉到她心情低落的时候。
Before October 7, Tana Rode knew next to nothing about Israel or Palestine. She told me maybe she'd seen a bumper sticker one time. Now she was responsible for this Palestinian kid. She read everything she could, tracked the news. She followed the numbers. November, more than 10,000 Palestinians dead. By Christmas, 20,000. Tana had a brand new awareness, an alarming awareness, of just how vulnerable Majd's family was. She worried.
10月7日之前，Tana Rode对以色列或巴勒斯坦几乎一无所知。她说也许曾在某个地方见过保险杠贴纸。现在她要负责这个巴勒斯坦孩子。她阅读了能找到的一切，追踪新闻。她关注数字。11月，超过1万名巴勒斯坦人死亡。圣诞节时，达到2万。Tana对Majd家人的脆弱处境有了全新的、令人震惊的认知。她很担心。
Every single day thinking about, am I going to get the call at work? Is today the day that her family's gone? Like every single day. And, oh, my god, I don't want to have to tell her.
每天都在想，我在工作时会接到那个电话吗？今天就是她家人出事的那一天吗？就像每天都在想。噢，天哪，我不想必须告诉她。
Tana, were you imagining this kid is my responsibility if she loses her family?
Tana，你有没有想过这个孩子如果失去家人，我该怎么办？
Yes. Absolutely.
有的。绝对有。
Tana wasn't the only host mom who told me this. Farah's host mom in Oklahoma told me she and her husband sat down together and walked through the different scenarios so they'd know what they were OK offering if they needed to offer. Fatima overheard her host mother call a friend who had hosted a Ukrainian student to ask for advice, just in case.
Tana不是唯一跟我说这些的寄宿妈妈。Farah在俄克拉荷马州的寄宿妈妈告诉我，她和丈夫坐在一起，梳理了各种情境，这样如果需要的话，他们知道自己能够提供什么帮助。Fatima无意中听到她的寄宿妈妈给一个曾经接待过乌克兰学生的朋友打电话寻求建议，以防万一。
January 2024. Majd told her dad if he wasn't going to leave Gaza for himself, he should at least do it for her younger sister. The argument Majd made, it was very her. Majd told him, she's 12 years old. She needs to be in school. Without an education, what kind of future will she have? Her dad relented.
2024年1月。Majd告诉爸爸，如果他不为自己离开加沙，至少为了妹妹也应该走。Majd提出的理由非常“Majd”。Majd告诉他，她才12岁。她需要上学。没有教育，她会有什么样的未来？爸爸妥协了。
Tana, her host mom, helped Majd to raise money to get her parents out of Gaza. February, her family made it out of Gaza. Majd got a message.
寄宿妈妈Tana帮助Majd筹集了资金，让她的父母离开了加沙。2月，她的家人成功逃离了加沙。Majd收到了一条消息。
I was about to lose hope. But then one day, he just called me and said, oh, hey, we're traveling tomorrow.
我差点绝望了。但有一天，他给我打电话说，噢，嘿，我们明天出发。
What did it feel like when you were like, they are there?
当你意识到他们就在那里时，感觉如何？
I literally have no words to describe this. It feels like you were just burning in flames, and then somebody put water all over you. And now, yeah, you're not burning anymore. And I just went to school so happy that week. It was crazy. Everybody was noticing, even the teachers. And they said, oh, somebody's got good news here. What's going on? [LAUGHS] And, yeah, they were all so happy for me.
我真的找不到词来形容。感觉就像你一直在火焰中燃烧，然后有人往你身上浇了水。现在，是的，你不再燃烧了。那个星期我去学校时非常开心。太疯狂了。每个人都注意到了，连老师也是。他们说，噢，有人有喜事啊。怎么回事？[笑] 是的，他们都为我感到高兴。
The first half of Majd's year had been dominated by terrifying news from home and nightmares about her family and social isolation. She'd been under so much pressure. When this worry for her family lifted, Majd experienced a surge of energy. She was giddy. She wanted to do everything. She wanted to be a kid on the YES program, not just a kid in the midst of a war. She wanted to be like all the other YES students from all the other countries that she was seeing in her Instagram feed having a normal American year.
Majd这半年的生活一直被来自家里的可怕新闻和对家人的噩梦以及社交孤立所笼罩。她承受了太大的压力。当这份对家人的担忧消散后，Majd经历了一股能量的迸发。她变得兴奋不已。她想尝试一切。她想成为一个普通的YES项目学生，而不是一个处于战争中的孩子。她想变得像她在Instagram上看到的那些来自其他国家的YES学生一样，度过一个正常的美式一年。
I started to do golf a few days after my parents got out. Everything in life started to be better.
父母逃离几天后，我开始打高尔夫。生活中的一切都开始变好。
Why golf?
为什么是高尔夫？
I don't want to do a conventional sport. And I'm really bad at running. So, yeah, I didn't want to be too tired doing a sport, but I still wanted to enjoy it.
我不想做传统的运动。我跑步真的很差。所以，我不想在运动中感到太累，但我还是想享受它。
Golf was posted to Instagram.
高尔夫的动态被发布到了Instagram上。
Hey, Robin. She's never ridden in a golf cart before. Don't you have golf carts where you're from?
嘿，Robin。她以前从没坐过高尔夫球车。你家那边没有高尔夫球车吗？
No, we don't have golf. We don't have bowling. Nothing.
没有，我们没有高尔夫。我们没有保龄球。什么都没有。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
How would I get along over there? I don't know what I'd do.
我在那边怎么生活啊？我不知道我会干什么。
It wasn't just golf. She joined bowling. She tried tennis. She went to a Valentine's Day party-- posted.
不仅是高尔夫。她参加了保龄球。她试了网球。她去参加了情人节派对——发了动态。
(SINGING) We say ooh-wee-oh
(唱歌) 我们说，哦——
Wee-oh-wee-oh
哦——
A Super Bowl party.
超级碗派对。
(SINGING) Up in the club with my homies
(唱歌) 和我的哥们在俱乐部里。
Tryna get a little V-I
试着有点……
Messed around with helium balloons at a different party.
在另一个派对上玩了氦气球。
I don't know what to say.
我不知道说什么。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It makes your voice higher.
它会让你的声音变高。
Hello.
你好。
Majd was all in. She was saying yes to the life that was in front of her. Sometimes Majd got messages from people who were upset about her posts, but not nearly as many. And they didn't get under her skin in the same way as before. Majd showed me endless pictures and videos she took of kids having fun. And she's in these videos. She's not just documenting the fun. She's having fun.
Majd完全投入了。她对自己面前的生活说“YES”。有时Majd会收到对她发布的内容不满的人发来的信息，但数量少多了。而且它们不像以前那样触动她的痛处。Majd给我展示了她拍摄的无数孩子玩耍的照片和视频。她也出现在这些视频中。她不仅仅是在记录快乐。她也在享受快乐。
Something I love about Americans is that they love to be very silly. Like, this is one of my friends. He put the pom-pom on his head.
我喜欢美国人的一点是，他们喜欢表现得很傻。比如，这是我的一个朋友。他把毛绒球戴在头上。
I did not really understand what she was showing me in this picture, but what I got from it was Majd has friends.
我其实并不太明白照片里她在展示什么，但我从中得知的是：Majd有朋友。
And this is my other friend, Emily.
这是我的另一个朋友，Emily。
Oh.
噢。
My weekends are pretty full now. It's crazy.
我的周末现在排得很满。太疯狂了。
It was stunning to watch Majd rebound like this-- her stamina, grit. Just stunning. Stunning or concerning? Sometimes I wasn't sure.
看到Majd这样反弹，非常震撼——她的韧性和毅力。非常震撼。震撼还是令人担忧？有时我不确定。
All that stuff she just lived through was still living through. People were still getting bombed. Her parents were in an unstable situation. Their future-- and hers-- still very unclear. Was she just putting all that aside for now? Was that going to work? Maybe? At least it seemed like a really nice reprieve.
她刚刚经历的一切，其实仍在继续。人们仍在被轰炸。她的父母处于不稳定的状态。他们的未来——以及她的未来——仍然非常不明朗。她现在只是把这一切暂时搁置了吗？这管用吗？也许吧？至少这看起来像是一个非常美好的喘息机会。
March. Sometimes Majd would open Snapchat, and the app would send her a This Time Last Year with a picture of her and the other YES students in Gaza. Back then, they'd all just gotten accepted and were meeting and texting each other, becoming a group.
3月。有时Majd会打开Snapchat，应用程序会给她推送一个“去年的今天”，上面有她和加沙其他YES学生的照片。那时，他们刚被录取，正互相见面、发短信，组成了一个团队。
She'd get a pang of longing and anxiety. She missed them. She'd not heard from them in five months. Were they all still chatting all the time, just without her? Late at night, she'd stare at their profiles in bed, scrolling. And then finally, one night--
她会感到一阵渴望和焦虑。她想念他们。她已经五个月没收到他们的消息了。他们是不是还在聊天，只是没有她？深夜，她躺在床上，盯着他们的资料，刷着屏幕。然后终于，在一个晚上——
I reached out to one of the girls in the exchange program. And I told her, oh, my god, hi. How are you? She started talking to me a little bit in a cold way. So, yeah, I started being very friendly with her, like, oh, my god, I miss you so much. How's your year going? And I hope your family is safe and everything.
我联系了交换项目里的一个女孩。我对她说，噢，天哪，嗨。你好吗？她开始用冷淡的态度跟我说话。所以，我开始对她非常友好，说，噢，天哪，我太想你了。你这一年过得怎么样？希望你家人安全，一切都好。
And, yeah, she started talking normally. And then after two days, she stopped responding. And I'm like, what did I say? Well, what did I do? It got me feeling like all the exchange students are kind of against me, which they probably are, but.
是的，她开始正常交谈了。然后两天后，她就不回复了。我心想，我说错什么了吗？我做什么了？这让我觉得所有的交换生都有点针对我，虽然他们可能确实是这样。
They might not be.
也许不是。
I mean, maybe not all of them. There are two students that are really amazing, but now they don't really talk. But yeah, it's very confusing. There's going to be something going on. And I'm going to discover that when I see them again in June, so.
我是说，也许不是所有人。有两个学生真的很棒，但现在他们不怎么说话了。总之，这太令人困惑了。肯定发生了什么事。等到六月份见到他们时，我就知道了。
In June, when they'd all fly to DC, spend a few days at the State Department for the end of the year program, and then fly home. They couldn't fly home, right?
六月份，当他们飞往华盛顿特区，在国务院参加几天的项目结束活动，然后飞回家。他们不能飞回家，对吧？
All of the YES students from Gaza started the year planning to go back to Gaza. They were slowly realizing that was not going to happen. The war was not ending. What was going to happen at the end of the school year? That's coming up from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
所有来自加沙的YES学生在这一年开始时都计划回加沙。他们慢慢意识到那是不可能的。战争没有结束。学年结束时会发生什么？芝加哥公共广播电台的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. We're telling the story of a group of 13 students who came to the United States from Gaza last September to do a year of high school in America. They're on a program run by the State Department called YES.
这是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。我们正在讲述一群学生的故事，去年9月，13名学生从加沙来到美国，在美国读了一年高中。他们参加的是由国务院运营的YES项目。
We're in April 2024, two months before the end of the YES program. And then what? The YES kids were pinning their hopes on this. The year before, the State Department had extended the program for some Ukrainian YES students, gave them another year in the US. That's what Majd was hoping for.
现在是2024年4月，距离YES项目结束还有两个月。然后呢？YES孩子们把希望寄托在这上面。前一年，国务院为一些乌克兰YES学生延长了项目时间，让他们在美国多待了一年。那正是Majd所希望的。
But then the State Department sent letters to the kids saying they would not be extending the program for the 13 students from Gaza. The program would end June 6.
但随后国务院给孩子们发了信，说他们不会为来自加沙的13名学生延长项目时间。项目将于6月6日结束。
You've got to figure everything out by yourself. And I'm like, we're 16-year-olds. We can't just come up with something from thin air. We need some sort of help.
你必须自己解决一切问题。我心想，我们才16岁。我们不能凭空变出个计划来。我们需要一些帮助。
The State Department says it did provide support to students, that the health, safety, and security of all students was their top priority. Their goal was to reunite students with their families. And they say they worked closely with them on their post-program plans. They also say they provided an equally rigorous process for exchange students from both Ukraine and Gaza.
国务院表示，他们确实为学生提供了支持，所有学生的健康、安全和保障是他们的首要任务。他们的目标是让学生与家人团聚。他们说，他们与学生就项目结束后的计划进行了密切合作。他们还表示，为来自乌克兰和加沙的交换生提供了同样严格的流程。
But what Majd and the other students from Gaza describe is feeling like they were on their own to come up with a plan. Even for Majd, a master planner of her own life, this was a lot. She looked at her options.
但Majd和其他来自加沙的学生所描述的情况是，他们感到只能靠自己来制定计划。即使对Majd这个自己生活的策划大师来说，这也太多了。她审视了自己的选择。
Her parents didn't think it made sense for her to come to Egypt. Their situation wasn't stable. Like all Palestinians who fled Gaza, they weren't allowed to work in Egypt. Everything was incredibly expensive. As of April, her sister wasn't even able to go to school. If Majd joined them, it wasn't clear how she'd continue her education in Egypt, if the family could even continue staying there.
她的父母认为她去埃及没有意义。他们的处境并不稳定。像所有逃离加沙的巴勒斯坦人一样，他们在埃及不被允许工作。一切都贵得离谱。截至4月，她的妹妹甚至无法上学。如果Majd去投奔他们，她如何在埃及继续接受教育都不清楚，甚至家庭能否继续留在那里都是问题。
So Majd frantically searched for boarding schools in the US with scholarships that might be able to extend a student visa in America. But the deadlines to apply had passed. She learned everything she could about immigration law. She had relatives in Michigan. She could maybe move in with them. But what were the schools like? And how would she get a lawyer and study and live? She ran it over and over in her head.
所以Majd疯狂地在美国寻找提供奖学金的寄宿学校，这些学校可能能够延长美国的学生签证。但申请截止日期已经过了。她尽可能多地学习移民法。她在密歇根州有亲戚。她也许可以搬去和他们住。但那里的学校怎么样？她如何请律师、如何学习和生活？她在脑子里反复推演。
OK, just say I move in with my relatives in the US and, OK, what next? I don't have the right documents to even get a job. We're not allowed to drive here. And I don't have health insurance. My insurance from the State Department ends soon. And then what am I going to do?
好吧，就算我搬到美国的亲戚家，好吧，接下来呢？我没有获得工作的有效证件。我们不允许在这里开车。而且我没有医疗保险。国务院提供的保险很快就要到期了。那我要怎么办？
I talked to my financial literacy teacher. She teaches us about insurance and stuff. She said, oh, you can buy it from Marketplace or something, but I don't work. I don't have an income to even pay for an insurance. So I don't know.
我跟我的理财老师谈过。她教我们保险之类的事情。她说，噢，你可以从保险市场买，但我没工作。我没有收入来支付保险。所以我不知道。
This was all of them. All 13 teenagers were scrambling to figure out what to do and where to go, calling their parents, talking with the State Department, and casting around randomly for advice, like Fatima.
他们所有人都遇到了这个问题。所有13名青少年都在拼命想办法该怎么做、去哪里，打电话给父母，与国务院交谈，并像Fatima那样随机寻找建议。
My friends were trying to help out. Some of them are like, do you have any people you know in the States? I'm like, I have relatives, but I don't know if it's going to be the right move to move with them.
我的朋友们试图帮忙。有些人说，你在美国有认识的人吗？我说，我有亲戚，但我不知道搬去和他们住是不是正确的选择。
This is you talking to other 15-year-olds, 16-year-olds?
这是你和别的15岁、16岁的孩子谈话？
Yeah. They just were asking me questions. And then after that, I was like, oh, that might be an option.
是的。他们只是问我问题。在那之后，我想，噢，那可能是一个选项。
Majd met with a lawyer who advised her pro bono. She says the lawyer told her to apply for asylum, move in with her relatives in Michigan, enroll in public school. There, she could do a senior year again, find scholarships to go to college in the US. Majd told me, I will not be going back to Gaza. She sounded a little stunned.
Majd见了一位律师，对方免费为她提供法律建议。她说律师建议她申请庇护，搬到密歇根州的亲戚家，在公立学校注册。在那里，她可以再读一年高三，寻找奖学金去美国上大学。Majd告诉我，我不会回到加沙。她听起来有点震惊。
Majd and I talked about a lot of devastating things, but this was really the only time I could tell she was taking in the meaning of what she was saying. It would be nearly impossible for her to leave the US while she waited for asylum. She had a new plan that she laid out for me. And at first, she had that eerie smile. But then it disappeared.
Majd和我谈论了很多令人痛苦的事情，但这真的是唯一一次，我能看出她在消化自己所说内容的含义。在她等待庇护期间，她几乎不可能离开美国。她向我提出了一个新的计划。起初，她露出了那种诡异的微笑。但随后，微笑消失了。
It just breaks my heart that a place where I grew up in, I just-- I just can't see that again. And the lawyer said that it's going to take from 7 to 10 years, at least, to get to an asylum interview because of the lack of asylum officers here in Washington.
我长大的地方，我只是……我再也见不到了，这让我心碎。律师说，因为华盛顿缺乏庇护官，等待庇护面试至少需要7到10年。
And I'm like, are you telling me I have to wait 7 to 10 years? I'm going to be graduating and having my whole career and life here until I get to an interview? And then I have to wait again to get the result? Yeah.
我心想，你是说我得等7到10年？我要在这里完成学业、拥有整个职业生涯和生活，直到我等到面试？然后还得等结果？是的。
And imagine not seeing my family all of that time. It's crazy. I'm 16 now. I'm imagining, like, OK, let's calculate just 10 years. I'm going to be at least 26 when I see them again. And, yeah, for me, I'm just telling you this.
想象一下那么长时间见不到我的家人。这太疯狂了。我现在16岁。我在想，好吧，算10年吧。等我再见到他们时，至少已经26岁了。是的，我只是告诉你这些。
But, yeah, I still don't process that because both of my parents, they have chronic-- oh, my god. I don't want to go into that aspect. But they have chronic illnesses, and who knows in 10 years if they're still going to be around or not? Oh, my god, this is hard. [SIGHS]
但，我还是无法接受，因为我的父母，他们有慢性病……噢，天哪。我不想谈论那个方面。但他们有慢性疾病，谁知道10年后他们是否还在？噢，天哪，这太难了。[叹气]
Yeah, that's super hard.
是的，那确实非常难。
[SIGHS] Yeah, so I'm going to see my sister when she's at least 23 years old. That's crazy. [SNIFFLING]
[叹气] 是的，我再见到我妹妹时，她至少23岁了。太疯狂了。[抽泣]
Majd puts her head down and starts sort of laughing.
Majd低下头，开始有点苦笑。
Tell me if you need a break or if it's too much. OK?
如果你需要休息或者觉得太难受了，告诉我。好吗？
Do you want to order food?
你想订点吃的吗？
Sure. Are you hungry?
当然。你饿吗？
Yes, she is. And yes, she does need a break. Majd would not be going back to Gaza. This year in America was not a year. It was her life.
是的，她饿了。是的，她确实需要休息。Majd不会回到加沙了。这一年在美国不是一年。那是她的人生。
[CAR DOOR SHUTTING]
[车门关上]
May. Tana, Majd's host mom, is driving her to Seattle. Majd is going for an overnight with friends. When she was back home in Gaza, Majd would come home after school and find her mom. She'd sit down wherever her mom was-- in the living room or the kitchen-- and talk. She'd talk about her day, her thoughts, her problems. She could go on and on until her mom usually kicked her out, telling her, OK, that's enough already. I've been listening to you talk for three hours.
5月。Majd的寄宿妈妈Tana正开车送她去西雅图。Majd要去朋友家过夜。当她在加沙时，Majd放学回家后会找妈妈。她会坐在妈妈所在的地方——起居室或厨房——聊天。她会谈论她的一天、想法、问题。她会一直说个没完，直到妈妈通常会把她赶走，说，好了，已经够了。我已经听你说了三个小时了。
In Bremerton, when Majd talks like this, it's either to the school nurse, Ms. Caroline, or Tana. She's in the front seat, texting and also talking at rapid speed. She's jumping from topic to topic, telling Tana, "One of my teachers has been out for two weeks. There's like an intern teaching us or something. Ugh, I should have had breakfast this morning. Did I tell you I'm running for prom court?"
在布雷默顿，当Majd像这样聊天时，听众要么是学校护士Caroline女士，要么是Tana。她坐在副驾驶座上，一边发短信一边高速说话。她话题跳跃，告诉Tana：“老师之一已经请假两周了。有个实习生在教我们什么的。呃，我今天早该吃早饭的。我跟你说过我在竞选返校节皇后吗？”
I don't know why I came up with that idea. Oh, my god. I don't know. It's so embarrassing for me to just ask people, oh, vote for me. Yeah, that's something I don't do. Yeah.
我不知道我怎么会有那个想法。天哪。我不知道。请求别人“噢，投票给我吧”，这对我很尴尬。是的，这是我不会做的事。是的。
That's how you get what you want in life. Just ask for it.
那正是你在生活中得到想要东西的方式。只要开口要就行。
[SIGHS] I don't want to be queen or anything, but at least on the court, you know?
[叹气] 我不想当什么皇后，但至少在候选名单里，你知道吗？
She tells Tana, "I probably won't get it. I'm not exactly your typical pick." But, Majd says, recently, people seem so interested in her. She thinks it might be because college students are protesting the war in Gaza. It's all over the news. Kids in her high school suddenly know about Gaza.
她告诉Tana：“我可能选不上。我不是那种典型的候选人。” 但Majd说，最近人们似乎对她很感兴趣。她认为可能是因为大学生在抗议加沙战争。新闻里到处都是。她高中的孩子们突然知道了加沙。
It's just that a lot of people come up to me and saying, oh, god. Yeah, I understand what you're going through, or, I feel for you. And if you need to talk to someone, I'm here. People are starting to be really nice about it. Yeah, actually, some girl, a while ago, she came up to me and gave me a teddy bear for, like, oh, my god. Hey, I feel for you. I sent you that picture.
只是很多人过来跟我说，噢，天哪。我理解你的遭遇，或者，我为你感到难过。如果你需要找人说话，我在这里。人们开始在这件事上变得非常好。事实上，不久前有一个女生，她过来给了我一只泰迪熊。
Yes, you did.
是的，你给了我。
And yeah, I was like, oh, my god, thank you so much, you know?
我心想，噢，天哪，非常感谢，你知道吗？
Majd tells Tana she was up late last night worrying about seeing the other YES students from Gaza in DC. She just realized how soon it is. "I'm going to find out why they all stopped talking to me," she says. "Ugh, who's my roommate going to be?" There's a pause. Majd stares out the window. And then--
Majd告诉Tana她昨晚一直担心去华盛顿特区见到加沙的其他YES学生，彻夜难眠。她意识到时间快到了。“我终于要弄清楚为什么他们都不理我了，”她说。“呃，我的室友会是谁？” 停顿了一下。Majd凝视着窗外。然后——
The other day, I was talking to my mom. And I don't know why I said something so randomly. But I just started crying out of nowhere because I didn't remember how the inside of our fridge looked like.
前几天，我和妈妈通电话。不知道为什么我突然说了一些莫名其妙的话。我突然就开始哭，因为我不记得家里的冰箱里面长什么样了。
You don't?
你不记得了？
No, I don't remember anything from our house now. It's crazy. I remember how it looks like, yeah, but the details of it, they're so blurry now.
不，我现在不记得家里的任何细节了。太疯狂了。我记得它看起来像什么，但细节现在变得很模糊。
Another pause.
又停顿了一下。
How long is this going to go for, you know? I don't know.
这要持续多久，你知道吗？我不知道。
They pull into Seattle. Majd hops out, throws her backpack on. Her attention swings from Gaza back to America. And maybe this is just how she's going to keep dealing with all this-- dipping into the sadness for a minute and then flipping back. She goes to her sleepover. They visit the Space Needle. She watches Star Wars for the first time.
他们开车进入西雅图。Majd跳下车，背起书包。她的注意力从加沙转回了美国。也许这就是她处理这一切的方式——沉浸在悲伤中一会儿，然后翻篇。她去参加过夜派对了。他们参观了太空针塔。她第一次看了《星球大战》。
It was very fun. Yeah, we did like a Star Wars marathon.
非常有趣。是的，我们还搞了星球大战马拉松。
[LAUGHS] It's like 10 hours or something, isn't it? How many hours is that?
[笑] 那大概有10个小时左右吧？一共几个小时？
12, something like that. Yeah, it was amazing. We stayed up all night, eating.
12个小时，差不多吧。太棒了。我们整晚没睡，一直在吃东西。
Well, you sound really happy.
嗯，你听起来真的很开心。
Yeah.
是啊。
That same week, Majd went to prom. And she won prom court. June. Majd is leaving Washington State, heading to DC. She's thinking about her year and about seeing the other students, just thinking. And she has a new theory about why they're not in touch. She thinks it goes back to when they first met, back in Gaza, when they all got into the YES Program.
同一周，Majd参加了毕业舞会。她入选了舞会候选名单。6月。Majd离开华盛顿州，前往华盛顿特区。她思考着这一年，思考着要见到其他学生，只是在思考。她有了一个关于为什么他们不联系她的新理论。她认为这追溯到他们第一次见面的时候，回到加沙，回到他们刚被YES项目录取的时候。
Before I came to the US, I was just very academic-oriented. Yeah, I only focused on my studies. I mean, I still do here. But, yeah, that can be a factor of why they didn't really like me that much.
来到美国前，我完全以学术为导向。在这里也一样。但在加沙，可能就是为什么他们不喜欢我的一个原因。
Like they thought you were too obsessed with school?
就像他们认为你对学校太着迷了？
Mm-hmm. Yeah, I kind of talked about it a little too much. Yeah. Like scholarships and academics in general.
嗯。是的，我聊得有点太多了。奖学金和学术之类的话题。
Wow, Majd, that's a huge realization.
哇，Majd，那是个巨大的觉悟。
Yeah, I know. It's hard to see yourself from other people's point of views.
我知道。站在别人的角度审视自己真难。
Yeah. But you had that realization without anyone telling you that?
是的。但你是在没有人告诉你的情况下，自己意识到的？
Yeah, nobody ever told me that. I mean, it would have helped so much if somebody actually pointed that out so I could notice.
是的，没有人告诉过我。如果有人指出来，我能注意到，那会有很大帮助。
Yeah, how did you get there?
你是怎么得出这个结论的？
All this last month, when my friends were just saying goodbye to me, and we're hanging out a lot, they're saying, oh, my god, you're such a fun person.
这最后一个月，当朋友们跟我道别，我们经常聚在一起时，他们说，噢，天哪，你是个这么有趣的人。
Or, like, one of my friends signed my yearbook. And he said, "Everybody's lucky to have you as a friend in their life." And I'm like, oh my god, this feels so weird. But then I realized that, hey, I actually am a fun person here in the US. Yeah, I'm not the same as I was in Gaza.
或者，有个朋友在我的毕业纪念册上写道：“大家能有你这样的朋友真是幸运。” 我心想，天哪，这感觉太奇怪了。但我意识到，嘿，我在美国其实是个有趣的人。我不像在加沙时那样了。
I'm even remembering when you said to me that you were trying to yell like Americans do, but you couldn't make yourself do it. You remember that?
我甚至记得你说过你试着像美国人那样尖叫，但做不到。记得吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I could not bring myself to be silly at any time, but now it's just like, yeah, I'm chilling. Yesterday, I was just chilling and watching cartoons.
是啊。我以前任何时候都无法强迫自己变得傻气，但现在就像……我放松了。昨天，我只是在放松看动画片。
I went down to Washington, DC, to talk to the other YES kids. This terrible year was ending here, strangely.
我去了华盛顿特区，与加沙的其他YES学生谈话。这可怕的一年在这里奇怪地结束了。
[CHATTER]
[交谈声]
Hundreds of teenagers from all over the world fill an auditorium at the State Department. Lots of lanyards and hugs. All the different countries are vying for any open space to take a group photo. The Ghanaians are really going to have to sort out which camera everyone is supposed to look at. The staff is trying to get everyone seated.
数百名来自世界各地的青少年挤满了国务院的礼堂。挂绳和拥抱随处可见。所有不同的国家都在争夺任何空地来拍集体照。加纳人得好好商量每个人该看哪个镜头。工作人员试图让大家就座。
Good morning, and welcome, YES students. And congratulations on a successful year. Let's give you all round of applause, just to get started. Woo-hoo!
早上好，欢迎YES学生们。祝贺你们度过了成功的一年。让我们给所有人鼓掌，先开始吧。喔吼！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
But the 13 kids from Gaza are not here. They're in a separate building by themselves with a counselor. And I'm not allowed there. They have a different program because unlike the other kids, they are not going home. The hundreds of other YES students are celebrating their achievements. They're standing up one by one.
但那13名来自加沙的孩子不在这里。他们由一名顾问带领，在另一栋单独的建筑里。我不被允许进去。他们有一个不同的项目，因为和其他孩子不同，他们不能回家。数百名其他YES学生正在庆祝他们的成就。他们一个接一个地站起来。
A kid from Pakistan says his favorite part of the year was Christmas. He got to go caroling with his host family in California. It was amazing. A girl from Kosovo says she played basketball for the first time.
一个来自巴基斯坦的孩子说他这一年最喜欢的部分是圣诞节。他在加州和寄宿家庭一起去唱颂歌。太棒了。一个来自科索沃的女孩说她第一次打了篮球。
I actually got to be in the senior night also with all of the varsity girls.
我实际上也参加了所有校队女生的“高三之夜”。
Latoya from Liberia won an award for debate. Danielle from Indonesia got awarded the most spirited cheerleader ever. Zan from the Philippines was cast as the lead in two school plays.
来自利比里亚的Latoya获得了辩论奖。来自印度尼西亚的Danielle被授予“最精神抖擞的拉拉队长”。来自菲律宾的Zan在两部学校剧目中担任主角。
Now, before I came to America, I didn't really know what theater was. I didn't know that I was going to fall in love with it. But my host dad was a theater teacher, and he introduced me to many musicals and many plays. And I was lovestruck. Lovestruck, basically. And--
在我来美国之前，我真的不知道什么是戏剧。我不知道自己会爱上它。但我的寄宿爸爸是一名戏剧老师，他向我介绍了许多音乐剧和戏剧。我被迷住了。基本上，我坠入了爱河。而且……
Finally--
最后——
I wish you all safe travel home, big hugs with your family, and we hope you come back again on another program in the future. Thank you.
祝愿大家一路平安，和家人紧紧拥抱，我们希望未来你们能参加另一个项目回来。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
[掌声，欢呼声]
I did manage to talk to many of the 13 students from Gaza over the next several weeks, and I got an answer to the question Majd had obsessed over all year-- what happened? Why did they all go quiet? It's true, some of them did find her focus on achievement annoying. Some of them had issues with some of her posts. But that is not what happened.
在接下来的几周里，我确实和那13名来自加沙的学生中的许多人谈过，我得到了一个Majd纠结了一整年的问题的答案——发生了什么？为什么他们都沉默了？没错，有些人确实觉得她对成就的执着很烦人。有些人对她的一些动态有意见。但这并不是全部真相。
Aboud, the friend Majd applied with, the very first person she called when she got into the YES Program, he went to Minnesota. And he told me after he learned his friend's family had been killed, after watching a video of his friend pulled out of the rubble, he kept going through the motions for a little while, but then--
Aboud，和Majd一起申请的朋友，她被录取时第一个给她打电话的人，他去了明尼苏达。他告诉我，在得知朋友全家遇难，看到朋友从废墟中被拉出的视频后，他坚持了一会儿正常生活，但随后——
I just couldn't. It was in my eyes. The tears were in my eyes. I remember I cried. I cried at night. And I did the day after and the day after. I didn't want to talk to anybody. I didn't want to see anybody. I didn't want to get out of bed. Didn't want to interact with anybody. I just wanted to not be.
我实在无法继续。它就在我眼前。泪水在眼眶里打转。我记得我哭了。晚上我哭了。第二天，第三天我也哭了。我不想和任何人说话。不想见到任何人。不想起床。不想与任何人互动。我只是想……不存在。
Eventually, Aboud says emotional numbness kicked in and never really went away.
最终，Aboud说情感麻木占据了上风，而且再也没有真正消退过。
It's like a black hole. It's sometimes just sucking all of your organs in, and sometimes it's just looming. Yeah, this is kind of how I feel it.
这就像一个黑洞。有时它会吸走你所有的器官，有时它只是若隐若现。是的，这就是我感受到的。
Were you in touch with the other Gazan exchange students during that time?
在那段时间里，你和其他加沙交换学生有联系吗？
At least I tried to contact them a few times to tell them like, hey, how are you? If you need anything, I'm here for you. But deep down, I knew I was just saying this to say this because I couldn't tolerate.
至少我试过几次联系他们，说，嘿，你好吗？如果你需要什么，我在这里。但内心深处，我知道我只是客套一下，因为我无法承受。
You couldn't actually be there for them.
你无法真正出现在他们身边。
Yeah. And that's something I'm not very proud of. Sometimes I would ghost people because I didn't have the capacity to deal with people.
是的。我对此并不感到自豪。有时我会故意“失踪”，因为我没有能力去应付人。
The whole year, Majd had wondered the most natural 16-year-old question-- what is everyone thinking about me? The answer is they weren't thinking of her. Here's Shahd. She was in Ohio.
整整一年，Majd一直在问最自然的16岁孩子的问题——大家是怎么看我的？答案是他们根本没在想她。这是Shahd，她在俄亥俄州。
I don't know. I believe everyone was just too much focused on their own drama. I mean, I was focused on my host family. If they see me talking to someone in Arabic, they would make a huge deal. So I was like, no, I'm going to limit that.
我不知道。我相信每个人都太专注于自己的痛苦了。我的意思是，我专注于我的寄宿家庭。如果他们看到我用阿拉伯语和别人交谈，他们会大惊小怪。所以我心想，不，我要限制这一点。
And then I was focused too much about knowing if my parents were alive or dead, and then focusing about how I'm going to manage to make friends in high school with people who don't even like my identity, and then fighting with my US history teacher so he could make me present about my country.
然后我太专注于确认我的父母是死是活，专注于如何在高中里与那些甚至不喜欢我身份的人交朋友，以及与我的美国历史老师争论，好让他让我演讲关于我国家的情况。
It was mainly just everyone so much focusing on their drama that no one actually had the time or even thought about just talking to each other. I was even scared to ask them what their situation of their family was because I didn't want to hear someone saying that, oh, my brother died, or, oh, my cousin was shot, or something like that. Because I always felt like-- I mean, in my mind, I'm going to go and tell him or talk to them about what's going on with my family, but they could be going through something worse.
主要是每个人都太专注于自己的痛苦，没有人有时间或甚至想到互相聊聊。我甚至害怕问他们家里的情况，因为我不想听到有人说，噢，我哥哥死了，或者，噢，我堂兄被枪杀了，诸如此类。因为我总是觉得——我是说，在我的脑海里，我想去告诉他们或谈论我家里的情况，但他们可能正在经历更糟糕的事情。
This, I heard again and again. Things were bad for me, but I didn't want to tell anyone about it because it could have been worse for someone else. So they didn't talk. Majd was alone in her experience, and so were all of them. They all went through a terrible thing separately. And then they continued on alone.
这番话我听过一次又一次。我过得很糟糕，但我不想告诉任何人，因为别人可能过得更糟糕。所以他们没有交流。Majd在她的经历中感到孤独，他们所有人也一样。他们都各自经历了一件可怕的事情。然后他们继续独自前行。
Farah and Fatima went to Egypt to be with their parents. They are both right now trying to figure out how to enroll in school there, which involves finding money and being sent from one government office to another, asked to provide paperwork from educational institutions that no longer exist.
Farah和Fatima去了埃及和父母团聚。她们现在都在尝试弄清楚如何在当地学校注册，这涉及筹钱和被一个政府部门推诿到另一个政府部门，被要求提供已不存在的教育机构的文件。
Ali is applying for asylum, like Majd. Aboud and Shahd both got into boarding school in the United States, Aboud in rural New Mexico. When I asked what he knew about what it was like there, he said, have you seen The Shining, you know, the castle? That's what it looks like.
Ali像Majd一样申请庇护。Aboud和Shahd都进入了美国的寄宿学校，Aboud在俄亥俄州的新墨西哥州农村。当我问他那里的情况时，他说，你看过《闪灵》吗？那个古堡？看起来就像那样。
They were supposed to be a crew, the YES '24 group. They were supposed to take a group picture and add it to the end of their Instagram highlights and then travel home and hug their parents and present about their experiences in classrooms-- mini celebrities in a place most of them expected to live the rest of their lives. They were supposed to be the group of alumni on stage in high school auditoriums in Gaza, telling the younger kids, you got to go. It'll change your life.
他们本应该是一个团队，“YES 24”小组。他们本应该拍一张集体照并加到Instagram精选的末尾，然后回家，拥抱父母，在教室里讲述他们的经历——在大部分人预期度过余生的地方成为迷你小名人。他们本应该是加沙高中礼堂台上那群校友，告诉学弟学妹们，你们一定要去。那会改变你的一生。
Majd is in Michigan now. She's moved in with her relatives.
Majd现在在密歇根州。她搬去和亲戚住了。
How is it?
感觉怎么样？
It's been a little weird. The culture definitely is different here.
有点奇怪。这里的文化肯定是不一样的。
Like, what kind of thing?
比如，什么方面？
I mean, family gatherings and the kinds of foods that they make and going to the mosques, seeing the community and everyone. And, yeah, it all reminds me of home. I find myself very sad and even crying sometimes because I want to be doing these things with my own family.
我是说，家庭聚会、他们做的食物类型、去清真寺，看到社区和每个人。这一切都让我想起家。我发现自己非常难过，甚至有时会哭，因为我想和自己的家人一起做这些事。
Majd sounds so much older to me ever since she arrived in Michigan. There's less of the urgent, hyper kid. She's sad sometimes, but she sounds solid. She's talking about what happened last year, in Arabic, talking about her family with people who actually know her family. It's enough like home at her aunt's house that it's not really possible for her to set everything aside. She has to find a place for it.
自从Majd到了密歇根州，她在我听来成熟多了。少了那种紧迫、活跃的孩子气。她有时会难过，但听起来很稳重。她会用阿拉伯语谈论去年发生的事情，和真正认识她家人的亲戚讨论她的家庭。姑姑家的一切足以让她感觉像家，所以她无法再把一切搁置在一边了。她必须找个地方安放这段记忆。
She's noticing when she smiles as she's saying sad things, trying not to do that. She started therapy. And she started school again. She needs more credits to graduate. Majd is doing another senior year, a senior year she never planned on. This time, she's not trying to make it perfect.
她开始注意到自己在说伤心事时会微笑，并试图改掉。她开始接受治疗。她又重新开始上学了。她需要更多的学分才能毕业。Majd正在度过另一个高三，一个她从未计划过的高三。这一次，她不再试图让它变得完美。
["THIS MUST BE THE PLACE" BY KISHI BASHI]
Today's program was produced by Miki Meek and edited by Nancy Updike. The people who put together today's show include Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Dana Chivvis, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Henry Larson, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Ryan Rumery, Amelia Schonbek, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
今天的节目由Miki Meek制作，Nancy Updike编辑。参与制作今天节目的人员包括Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Dana Chivvis, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Henry Larson, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Ryan Rumery, Amelia Schonbek, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, 和 Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Hany Hawasly, Eli Saslow, Michelle Navarro, Safiyah Riddle, Milca De Paz, Amalia Campbell, Reba Myall-Martin, Racceb Arikew, Chris Page, Jennie Hester, and the Snyder Methodist Church, and all the parents of all the YES students and their host families in America who spoke with us.
我们的执行主编是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。特别感谢今天的Hany Hawasly, Eli Saslow, Michelle Navarro, Safiyah Riddle, Milca De Paz, Amalia Campbell, Reba Myall-Martin, Racceb Arikew, Chris Page, Jennie Hester, 以及 Snyder卫理公会教堂，感谢所有与我们交谈过的YES学生父母和在美国的寄宿家庭。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our boss, Ira Glass. He's actually visiting Torey Malatia this week.
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。你可以免费收听我们超过800集的节目存档。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）提供给公共广播电台。一如既往感谢我们的老板Ira Glass。他这周去拜访Torey Malatia了。
We have separation anxiety. We have to be together.
我们有分离焦虑。我们必须在一起。
Weirdly, Ira said someone named Mark has been keeping them apart.
奇怪的是，Ira说有个叫马克的人一直在阻碍他们。
I'm like, Mark, please let us be together.
我说，马克，请让我们在一起吧。
I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. Join us next week for more stories of This American Life.
我是Chana Joffe-Walt。下周请继续收听更多的《美国生活》故事。
["THIS MUST BE THE PLACE" BY KISHI BASHI]